est une entreprise bio pharmaceutique
internationale qui se focalise sur les
aires thérapeutiques sont l'oncologie
les neurosciences et les maladies rares
Ipsen a une stratégie d'openingation
c'est à dire une stratégie patronale
avec des startups pour avoir un
portefeuille large dans le domaine
d'intérêt c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons un partenariat de longue date
avec le sprint Paris-Saclay
Epson est une entreprise avec des
racines françaises familiales ce qui
nous permet à des développements long
terme et des stratégies long terme nous
sommes implantés en France dans les
territoires de l'Île-de-France mais
aussi à Dreux et dans le sud de la
France assigne avec des usines nous
avons donc une présence dans
l'écosystème qui est riche et nous
sommes très engagés avec l'innovation en
santé au travers de partenariats avec
France Biotech sur le mentorat sur le
Spring Paris-Saclay en terme
d'innovation locale mais aussi au
travers de collaborations avec des
startups françaises qui sont présentes
au sein de notre portefeuille
le cadre du partenariat avec le sprint
Paris Saclay nous avons eu l'opportunité
aujourd'hui de rencontrer 6 des
finalistes du Spring 50 nous avons
organisé une table ronde avec les
directeurs de l'innovation chez Ipsen
pour discuter du partenariat en
entreprise des attentes des industriels
et comment on pouvait collaborer de
façon complémentaire entre startups et
grands groupes itsen a donc participé au
jury sprint 50 dans le cadre de Lewarde
pour la santé des biotech on a été ravi
d'être président du jury pour la
deuxième année consécutive on a été ravi
de remettre un prix à la start-up si
génétique ce qui a gagné le prix du du
jury c'est une start-up qui développe
des biopsie liquides et avec une
technologie particulière et nous pensons
que c'est une amélioration importante au
service des patients
[Musique]